- [Voiceover] So we're told let f of x
equal two x squared minus 18 over g of x
where g of x is a polynomial.
And then they tell us,
which of the following is
a possible graph of y is equal to f of x?
And they gave us four choices here.
And like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you could give a go at it.
Look at our f of x
and think about which of these graphs
actually match up or could match up
to that f of x?
All right, now let's work
through this together.
And they don't give us
a lot of information.
They don't tell us anything
about the denominator
of this rational expression.
They do tell us it's numerator.
And like we've seen before,
it's useful to factor
the numerator and see,
and what x values do
interesting things happen.
And particular, at what x values
does the numerator equal zero?
So if we factor the numerator up here,
we could rewrite f of x
as being equal to, let's see
we could factor out a two
out of the numerator.
So it's two times x squared minus nine.
And that's all going to be over g of x.
We don't know what the denominator is.
We just know that it's a polynomial.
Now see, here are the numerator
x squared minus nine.
You might recognize that.
It's a difference of squares
so we can factor that further.
So we still have that original two
and it's going to be x plus three
times x minus three.
We've seen that multiple times.
If that looks unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to watch the video
on differences of squares
or factoring polynomials.
X squared minus nine is the same thing
as x squared minus three squared.
So it's x plus three times x minus three.
And then all of that is still
going to be over g of x.
So the first thing that we might realize,
okay, when is our numerator equal zero?
Well, when x is equal to negative three
or when x is equal to positive three.
If x is equal to negative three,
this expression is going to be zero.
If x is equal to positive three,
this expression is equal to zero.
So you might just say,
"Oh, maybe we have zeros
"at plus or minus three."
So maybe at x is maybe,
maybe f of negative three
is equal to zero
and f of positive three
is equal to zero.
Those values sure look they made
the numerator equal to zero.
And then we look at our choices.
And when we look at our choices,
this choice A does seem to have a zero
at positive three
but it doesn't have one at negative three.
It has a vertical asymptote
at negative three.
So that seems a little bit confusing.
This choice B does have a zero
at positive three
but it has nothing going on here at,
or nothing interesting
on at negative three.
It defines negative three.
It doesn't even have a
vertical asymptote there.
So once again, this looks
a little bit perplexing.
Choice C has a removable discontinuity
at positive three
and then it has a vertical asymptote
at negative two.
So once again, this doesn't have anything
interesting going on at x
is equal to negative three.
So still a little perplexing.
And this one has a zero
at positive six and negative six.
So none of the choices had zeros
at both x equals positive three
and x equals negative three.
So, what's going on?
Well, what we need to realize is
just because something makes the numerator
equal to zero doesn't mean
that it's definitely going to
be a zero for that function.
And you might say,
"Well, how can that be?"
Well, think about situations
in which those values
would also make the
denominator equal to zero.
So let me write out some
potential f of x is here.
So we just know that g
of x is a polynomial.
So f of x could be, we know the numerator,
two times x plus three
times x minus three, over.
Well, let's just say g of x is,
I'm just gonna make up something,
g of x is equal to x plus one.
Well, in this situation,
none of the values
that make the numerator equal zero
make the denominator equal zero.
So this is a situation where
you would have two zeros
at x equals positive three
and x equals negative three.
So this would be the two zeros.
Two zeros.
And so let's look at
another similar situation.
Let's look at a situation where f of x
is equal to, you know, the numerator,
x plus three
times x minus three.
And let's say that we do have,
let's say that one of those x values,
positive or negative three,
do make the denominator equal to zero.
So let's say, x plus three
and then, say times x plus one.
Well, you see here, now since x plus three
is both the numerator and the denominator,
you could divide x plus three
divided by x plus three.
They cancel out.
And here x equals negative three
would be a removable discontinuity.
So this would have zero
at x equals three
and a removable discontinuity
at x equals negative three.
And so those values that make
the numerator equal to zero
we now see it could be a zero
or it could represent a
removable discontinuity.
And here I just pick a
removable discontinuity
be at negative three
or it could be the other way around
or it could be at both values.
If this was x plus three
times x minus three
over x plus three times x minus three,
then you would have a
removable discontinuity
at both x is positive
three and negative three.
And then you could go even further.
F of x could look like this.
It could be two times x plus three
times x minus three over
x plus three squared
and I'll just make up some
other, another expression here,
x plus one.
So, what's going to happen here?
Even if you divide the
numerator and the denominator
by x plus three, you're
still going to have
one x plus three left
over the denominator.
That could cancel with
one of the x plus threes
but you're still going
to have an x plus three.
And so in this case, you would
have a vertical asymptote.
So in this case, you would have a zero
at x is equal to three.
And you would have a vertical asymptote.
I'll just shorten it shorthand.
You would have a vertical,
I'll just write that out,
vertical asymptote
at x is equal to negative three.
So these particular examples
that I just showed you
showed you that any value that makes
the numerator equals zero
aren't necessarily zeros for the function.
They could be zeros.
They could be removable discontinuities
or they could be vertical asymptotes.
But they would all occur
at x is equal to positive
or negative three.
So if that lands, now let's
look at the choices again.
So choice A has a zero at
x equals positive three
and it has a vertical asymptote
at x equals negative three.
So that's actually very
consistent with this
situation that I just described.
So choice A actually
is looking pretty good.
Choice B has a zero at x equals three
but its vertical asymptote
looks like it's an x equals two
and nothing interesting is happening
at x equals negative three.
So we could rule that out.
If I look at choice C,
you have a removable discontinuity
at x equals positive three
which is completely possible.
We've seen that situation where something
that makes the numerator equals zero
could be a removable discontinuity
if you have that same
expression in the denominator.
But then the vertical asymptote
isn't that x equals negative three.
It's an x equals negative two.
So that rules it out.
Once again, nothing interesting happening
at x equals negative three.
And here you have two zeros
but they're not at x equals
positive or negative three.
They're x equals positive or negative six.
We can definitely rule that one out.
So we should feel pretty good about,
we should feel pretty good about choice A.